des centaines d'étudiants dispersé
violemment par la police turque
une nouvelle journée de manifestations
pour un mouvement qui ne s'essouffle pas
malgré 170 arrestations ce mercredi la
colère estudiantine s'empare de diverses
thématiques féminicide sort des kurdes
dans le pays et cette nouvelle
revendication les droits des personnes
lgbt suite à l'arrestation de quatre
étudiants accusé d'avoir insulté l'islam
en cause l'exposition d'un tableau
représentant la kaaba de la mecque ornée
de drapeaux arc en ciel face au
mouvement le président turc a réagi sans
détour nous ne considérons pas que ces
jeunes qui sont des membres
d'organisations terroristes ont
véritablement les valeurs nationales et
morale de notre pays
à l'origine de la contestation la
nomination en début d'année
universitaire d'un proche de rld aux
ânes à la tête de l'université du
bosphore laquelle avait toujours réussi
à préserver une forme d'autonomie
si les étudiants réclament sa démission
le nouveau recteur ne semble pas près de
céder
je suis une personne qui défend les
droits et les libertés les lgbt
je ne pense absolument pas à
démissionner je m'attendais dès le
départ à ce que cette crise puisse
prendre six mois pour être résolus et ce
sera ainsi le président turc craint que
la contestation étudiante ne se
transforme en manifestation anti
gouvernement comme en 2013 dans un pays
en pleine crise économique
recep tayyip erdogan se sait contesté et
a déjà en ligne de mire la future
élection présidentielle
l'enjeu pour le président turc rallier
ses troupes et conserver sa position de
rêve pour 2023